C'est ce que je voyais maintenant, c'est très bien, donc de temps en temps, faites un peu de bruit pour que ça soit positif.
Maintenant, on va commencer par la monétique, donc la monétique c'est quoi ? On va commencer par ce qui est la monétique,
et plus le temps passe, plus on va aller en zone dans telle ou telle partie.
Donc nous sommes tous amenés dans notre vie quotidienne de payer les biens ou des services.
C'est le quotidien, chacun de nous, donc la vie quotidienne, il doit payer des choses, il doit payer un service,
ou il doit payer un bien, il achète un bien, il achète quoi manger, il achète un du jour, il fait l'hôtel, quelque chose comme ça.
Pour faire le bien, continuez ce bien-là, il n'y a plus sur manière, il y a les billets blancs, il y a des chèques,
il n'y a vraiment de...
Et puis il y a ce qu'on appelle la carte bancaire. Vous voyez que la première des choses pour mettre un peu le carte, c'est que la carte bancaire est un moyen de paiement qui vient s'ajouter à notre moyen.
Donc c'est une continuité, c'est vrai que c'est une grande révolution, une grande révolution, une grande révolution parce que nous avions des moyens de paiement, maintenant il n'est plus simplifié, c'est tout.
Et vous pouvez le voir que dans ces quatre moyens de paiement, nous avons l'avant au quelqu'un qui joue le rôle de l'avant pour ce que c'est le système.
Parce que les moyens de paiement en réalité, le biais est en compte que le biais n'a pas de valeur, c'est parce que l'avant du pays, l'arrière, l'avant du centre du pays...
qui garantit la valeur, le chef l'a des choses, le chef la valeur est garantie par la haute,
qui a aimé le chef, le chef Moulton d'Atron. Donc, même la case bancaire, la case bancaire
en tant que classique, s'il n'y a pas un établissement derrière, donc aussi milliard
pour garantir la valeur, ça n'a aucune valeur. S'attentionnant, on va le retrouver
après. Acteurs directs, c'est-à-dire qu'il y a des acteurs qui sont là. Les acteurs qui
sont deux. Le premier acteur direct, c'est le porteur de la carte. Donc, je ne peux
pas imaginer une opération monique. Si je n'ai pas devant moi quelqu'un, il y a un
donc il y a quelqu'un qui doit avoir une carte entre elle on l'appelle en français porteur de
carte en anglais on l'appelle carrosat en arabe on l'appelle hanel bétard et bien sûr ce
porteur là il faut qu'elle trouve ou l'utiliser et ce qu'on appelle un commencant commencant au
merchant au télgiens si un établissement à qui je présente la carte et je présente la carte pour être
servi ça peut être un hôtel ça peut être un restaurant ça peut être un bijouci ça peut être
pissier automatique parce que le pissier automatique il est considéré comme un commencant particulier
pourquoi parce que je lui donne la carte et le môtre du cash donc nous avons deux
dire, quelqu'un qui est à la carte et quelqu'un qui va s'en servir et quelqu'un qui va
servir sa carte porteur comme un son. Et bien sûr, lorsqu'on parle des choses directes,
sûrement, il est juste indirect. La première des choses, c'est que moi en tant qu'emporteur,
je ne suis pas autorisé à faire la classe chez moi, je ne peux pas la faire et chez
moi, c'est pour cela qu'il y a ce qu'on appelle un acteur indirect. On appelle une émetture.
Émetture city, c'est un établissement qui est autorisé à donner des cas. Émetture,
on l'appelle échoueur, par exemple on appelle monstère le Gétard, qui est un qui a émetté la carte.
Parce que tous les porteurs ne sont pas autorisés à fabriquer eux-mêmes leurs cas.
Un commerçant, lorsqu'il va que c'était la carte de banqueur, il faut que l'on trouve derrière, oui, qu'il n'y a que le support par exemple au Maroc.
Chaque commerçant doit celer un contrat d'un commerçant au moins avec ses émits, sans marocains interbonquents.
Pourquoi ? Parce que moi, comme un commerçant marocain, je suis un client chinois, ou un client américain.
Comment je dois faire pour retrouver mon argent ?
Donc je suis besoin d'un appel à la paire.
La paire, on l'appelle à quoi elle est.
Donc il y a quelqu'un avec qui le porteur s'est rencontré.
La paire qui est importante, qui est la suivante.
Chaque fois qu'une carte est présente chez un client, chez un commerçant,
chaque fois qu'un porte-de-carte présente une carte chez un commerçant,
le commerçant ne peut vous donner l'argent, ne peut le servir
tant qu'il n'a pas eu un accord en réel de chez les metteurs,
en lui disant que la carte n'a pas de problème,
ce qu'on appelle l'autorisation.
Chaque fois qu'une carte est devant un commerçant,
le commerçant ne peut servir le porteur tant qu'il n'a pas poussé en temps réel une réponse,
en lui disant que la carte n'a pas de problème,
bien sûr le metteur peut lui dire que la carte n'a pas de problème,
mais c'est son rêve, parce que sinon le commerçant ne va pas être remboursé,
il ne va pas recevoir son âge.